Katie Couric speaks out on Matt Lauer's  painful firing from the Today Show the  61 year old journalist is finally  opening up after her former co-host was  fired from NBC in late November for  sexual misconduct after 20 years at the  company  Katie revealed to people hearing the  allegations of sexual misconduct against  Matt was quote painful for her  Katie served as Matt's today co-host for  nine years and told the publication she  was unaware of the claims made against  him  both while she was working at today and  after quote the accounts I've read and  heard have been disturbing distressing  and disorienting Lauer addressed the  allegations against him after he was let  go and apologized kate pensions me on  the Couric also touched on that joke she  made on watch what happens live in 2012  regarding her relationship with Lauer a  joke I once made on late-night  television was just that because it was  completely contrary to our  brother-sister relationship